so first off congratulations this is a
box-office smash this weekend which it's
so great because the hashtag choose kind
for the this day and age it's a it's a
little bit of a different message so
yeah amen to that
I said when when David and I first read
the book I checked back in the calendar
it was March of 2012 and we really
grasped onto that idea after reading
this book and saying to each other this
is something that we just have to do we
don't know how we're gonna do it but we
have to figure out a way to do this and
choose kind that idea of just putting
kindness out there into the world and
empathy was certainly a big part of that
yeah so I'm glad that that message is
resonating it did too you know and you
know I
I've reviewed this movie earlier in the
week and I didn't want to use the word
message and things because sometimes
people look at that like it's castor oil
I don't want to go see something with a
message but this is this has got
entertainment value and everything else
but it's got such a strong message which
I imagine is what appealed to you to
when you how did you get the book but
when you read it we were we were given
the book by an agent at UTA named Howie
Sanders David and I had lunch with him
and he said guys I've got a book for you
that I believe will be a perennial and
boy was he right and we know we read it
we fell in love with it we got on the
phone with RJ talk to her about what
with how we would want to make the movie
and kind of what we saw from the inside
out of it and then Gillian Boer who's
somewhere here in the audience I think
who has an executive was an executive at
Summit at the time and Lionsgate hi
Jillian she just reminded me that during
reshoots of a movie that we did called
warm bodies that david and i did with
her which is the wonder of zombie films
yeah it's the wonder of the message
there is love it was sweet zombie film
that I pitched through the book I
pitched you the book on those reshoots
and really and this is true there was
one company in the entirety of our
entertainment business that wanted to do
that wanted to take the risk on this
before the book had become the sensation
that was
at the time and Lionsgate and David you
know you had a relationship going back
obviously as an executive at Disney you
were on pretty woman and so Julia
Roberts had a you know a past with you
as it were which is nice to say we were
emailing this morning and said we've
done two films for the ages now and even
though it took 28 27 years in between
them Hey and and we were we were
reminiscing about it but we had offered
Julia
obviously many movies throughout the
years that didn't pan out or she wasn't
available or just didn't want to do them
and but one day I got a call from Kevin
Devane saying Julia read this book read
it to her kids and she wants to your
movie she wants to do something have
some it wasn't even a part of it you
know of being a part of this movie so
Tania and Kevin and Julia had lunch and
she wanted to play is about she wanted
to play Auggie's mom and we said yes and
then she waited with us for four years
until her three and a half years she
hung out just waiting for to happen and
be ready and then cleared her schedule
to do it which is we all know in this
room that just doesn't happen in
Hollywood so we were very happy and
grateful she did it and she did an
amazing job in the film now Stephen how
did you get involved in this because I
think you were offered this or they
approached you at one time and you had
to pass for reasons of your own but can
you tell us how you got involved
well I they sent it to me I was sent the
book right around the time that my son
Theodore was born and and I loved the
book and I wanted to do it but I
couldn't because when I did Perks my
daughter Macy had just been born and I
was on the road promoting and doing the
things I had to do and I wasn't there
for the first two months of basically
the first a month and a half of her life
off and on and as I promised myself I
would never do that again
ever for under any circumstances as much
as I love the book
so I passed and applause for never doing
that oh yeah okay her fatherhood yes but
I was always secretly hoping that that
it would come back around and it did and
I would say there are certain things the
movie gods really loved wonder because
in between the time I very begrudging
Lee said no and it came back around
these guys had done in another draft was
steve conrad and added some of the
magical realism and things that i
thought was we're just beautiful they
weren't there before i was terrific and
and it needed that it's not the way my
brain works when I saw it I was like oh
that's lovely but but yeah it worked out
you know and it became very personal to
me because it wanted thinking about it
in the the world that my son was gonna
go into and my daughter
they were about to enter the school and
I thought it could do some good for the
world and and I made it so far it kind
of bad you know and when you say family
and family movies and this is what they
call I think in the business a
four-quadrant movie because it has
appeal beyond just kids so I was going
for six you were going for a six
quadrant yeah that's among grandpa
everyone yeah yeah you know but not just
a kids movie as they say which is kind
of an insult in some ways to some well
that's a kids would this isn't it's a
family movie but they're rarer and rarer
in live-action you've got two of them
this year with Beauty and the Beast and
this mostly people identify them as
animated film season these days and I
used to say well growing up I saw a lot
of wonderful live action movies aimed at
the whole family and it's it's see and
when I saw this movie it reminded me of
that well I think there's also this it's
deceiving a little bit because on the
surface it would seem like this is a
movie about a young boy with a facial
difference but it's really a movie about
a family it's from perspectives there's
the parents story there's the teens
story there's the kids story there's
teachers stories so everyone can really
take something from it and what we're
seeing is as a result and I think would
also happen with the book is there's
groups of people that are going to see
it and then groups of people that are
coming away talking from it and that's a
beautiful thing to watch
well that's the decision to in adapting
you did it like the book from multiple
points of view and it's not just and I
get and it could have been just from
Auggie's point of view his story but
it's not it's his sister's just as
important in everything else well for me
when I went when they sent me the book
and I was reading it and I thought it
was lovely and it was so well written
and
he was endearing you know like Jack will
and I was like and I got to the part
where Jack will betrayed him and I
thought wow that was much darker than I
thought it was going to go but it was it
was around page 81 I turned the page and
it said via and when I realized oh this
is gonna be Ross her mom I know what
she's about to do and and it was what I
thought was a great book became classic
to me I was like I hope I hope that my
grandkids like read this in school
because because just by the sheer and
it's so simple but just by the sheer of
saying she's working RJ was working on
her own prejudice if you if you think
that you know this sister she's just
complaining about her little teenage
life or whatever and then you realize
how deep it goes then you realize what's
happening with her friend you can't help
but have empathy it is this structure
itself is is almost the message of
empathy it's the delivery system and I
thought it was revelry
so revolutionarily simple yeah I also
want to just say she does something so
subtle in the book but she covers a
microcosm of life she talks about this
family she talks about the wealthy kids
and families she talks about the poor
kids and family if you have a dog that
passes away she deals with alcoholism
she deals with divorce she deals with
bullying I mean this book is just packed
with themes and ideas and life and I
think that's what people are responding
and just one more thing about the the
points of view which was very important
was what I what we all felt very
strongly was you have to make it
understandable to a child you know you
have to be very direct okay now we're
gonna reset we're gonna go back to the
first day of school without those cards
without that approach it's like I think
most adult audiences would be able to
follow what was going on and understand
that we're jumping around in time but
it's so sophisticated but it had to be
done simply or else the whole thing is
if you're trying to teach a child in
some level to be maybe kinder it was
very important just aesthetically to do
it that way talk about the casting of
Jacob
Trombley in in that role obviously he
was fantastic in the movie room and he's
great in this too I mean and I can't
imagine first of all you're working with
kids animals makeup prosthetics I mean
this is your second film
Cley our budget was 250 million dollars
got a lot of extra - 230 - that's not
easy that's well you have a young child
actor and he goes through two hours of
makeup every day yeah yeah and yeah I
think that most we ever had Jacob for
one day was six hours so yeah it was
quite uh you know the ad department like
their their schedules that look like
john doe's notebook from seven it was
like really it was unbelievable how
intricate it was but Jacob look we met
him in Todd's office we were all there
he's such a charming boy and what we
loved all about an ovarian talked about
this what I took away from that is he's
such an ordinary kid he's so good and he
says he loves what we do so when it's
time to do it he does it he's wonderful
but otherwise he's just a kid in public
school Langley right outside of right
outside of Vancouver Canada and he's
just as normal as you can get and he's
really funny really funny and I thought
it was important that because I didn't
want argued ever feel like a victim and
I didn't want Auggie to feel like oh
poor him because that would be
counterintuitive the whole point which
is no he's an ordinary kid with this one
difference it's not a deformity it's a
difference and and I I knew that I don't
know we all felt it he would just have
that energy and he would bring it to
life he would always make it funnier or
plucky or or have more gumption than
anyone would anticipate because we just
didn't want to do a sappy like oh woe is
him kind of things that's not the point
congratulations and thanks for coming
out